the first thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna say we're going to work out what
Phi is and we're going to get Excel to
do it for us Excel is basically a big
glorified calculator okay that can do
loads of calculations all at once as
opposed to your your measly hand
calculator which you can only do you
know one at a time right this is a true
multitasker okay so he's only gonna do
the way to start and the calculation in
Excel is just a kid
equals okay so that tells Excel hey can
you can you work out what I'm about to
give you okay so if you remember we said
that be a numerical value of five was
equal this one plus root 5 on to okay
unfortunately are one of the
disadvantages of Excel is that it
doesn't deal my sleep with all of this
like so notation all that kind of thing
but will give us the numbers okay so I
want to input this into Excel right now
because it's a fraction and I want to
divide this whole numerator by 2 we're
gonna start with some brackets okay so
after your equal sign you slap in a
bracket say 1 plus now if you look on
your keyboard because the normal
keyboard there's no square root button
okay so in order to write a square root
you write squirt
because that's the abbreviation for
square root okay so you're in square
root and then in brackets fine that will
calculate the square root of 5 for you
like so okay and you'll see it's
recognizing that you're a skier to do a
calculation because there's like funny
colors and all that cut and menus come
up and now I'm going to close the
brackets so you'll notice I've got two
sets of brackets there I've got one
around the 5 and then I've got the 1
plus square root 5 that's the numerator
so far so good
okay now you'll also notice you don't
have a division button on your on your
keyboard but that's okay
all you need is that slash okay not to
be confused with the other slash I can
never remember working backwards and
which one's forwards but anyway that's
the one you want we'll divide by two
okay so this is a calculation we've told
it to do a calculation by pretty equal
science if you can enter you get a
number there now it says on mine it is
one point six very likely yours will
show more digits than that the reason
why can they do it's
just why might only shows my point six
it's because my fault really being at my
cells really small so if yours isn't the
same what we have to do is to increase
the size of a cell or the width of a
column and you can see I just go to that
border there and a little icon appears
on your on your mouse which says you can
change the width and there you go I've
got loads of digits there in fact if you
go up to if you've got your home ribbon
at the top visible okay I'm gonna make
this super wide for a second
I like that cell and then I want you to
look for an icon that looks like this
can you see that it's pretty small so
I'll draw it big on forward for you it
looks like this I think that's what it
looks like based on the icon what do you
think that's gonna do it's gonna
increase the number of decimal places
watch okay okay so I've got loads of
decimal places there I just don't need
to see all of them okay all right now
I'm just gonna put this back to a more
reasonable size down okay okay that'll
do all right so now what we're gonna do
is yeah oh yeah sure okay yeah no it's
not it's where it's where the computer
ends so in a similar way to your
calculator I'm working out a certain
amount of base image showing you only
some of them right all computers are
find out but surds go on forever right
so if my computer stored all the digits
even of just a simple calculation right
it would literally take all 160
gigabytes for the space of my computer
just to store a single number okay and
that's a concern smog forever turns out
forevers a long time okay so it would
take up all that space that's why there
is a limit by the way one more thing
I'll show you that I got real magnet if
you ever see that yo see now all that
means is the number you've got in there
is too large or has two decimal places
to fit in the cell okay because I mean
it's useful either so now we're going to
explore three
sequences sets of numbers that have an
order okay and here's my intention
number one I'm going to amaze you number
two I'm going to disappoint you and then
number three I'm going to lure you might
okay so ready here's what you do the
first series we're going to look at is
the Fibonacci sequence okay so you saw
these in the video I heard it was like
one of the very first things that are
opened weird okay so how do we get like
you guys can work out the Fibonacci
sequence but how can we get the computer
to do it for us he's work we're gonna
start first I want to label all of my
numbers okay so mathematicians often
start with zero rather than one so just
type in a zero there I've just got that
ISM actually make that in infant number
so I've got zero it's my starting point
and then I just want it to count down
one two three four five six seven for me
okay so in order
rather than me type out one two three
four five six seven I'm just going to
say equals who's done calculation and if
I just hit equals and the up arrow it's
going to go to the cell immediately
above me like that okay so now this this
cell that I'm looking at right now will
be that cell above me I'm gonna say plus
one okay so what's going to do is look
at the cell immediately about an ad
while and unsurprisingly you get one
okay but here's where it start to get
useful once you press ENTER you've gone
one then just copy that copy that cell
and now if you pasted it into a bunch of
cells so I just go on shift to highlight
those cells and I press paste it's
adding it's incrementing okay so that's
pretty simple right in fact I want more
than that I might go and I might
encourage you to go and maybe like 20
okay so I've got one got one between
that's okay all right
so heads up heads up to kill with me if
so far you're following yeah good hands
down I'll wait for everyone I'll give
you a couple of minutes more to see
what's going on
okay wait you already where you go what
I've got a my screen key you look up so
I know that we're ready to proceed
okay what was that okay
stop typing for a second watch it even
if you're not up to where we are - what
you get for now I'm going to do this
next step okay
what is the Fibonacci sequence how do we
actually calculate it within what we go
to the calculator and we know we define
what the first two numbers are Fibonacci
sequence are right well the first do
numbers there's actually two choices
which are both fine you can either say 0
+ 0 + 1 or you can saying one in one
okay for our purposes it doesn't
actually matter I'm just going to start
with one in one okay now after you
define the first two numbers is a simple
rule that gives you the rest of the
Fibonacci sequence which is if I want
this number the one that I don't have a
number for how do I calculate it I eat I
add up the previous two numbers right so
let's think about how we do this Excel
we want a calculation so the first thing
I should type is equals right and then I
want the two cells above me so I press
up to give me the cell phone
I press plus 2 given a song right and
then I press up twice to go the cell
above that does that make sense
see what I've got that we should all
have the same thing there I'm adding up
the two cells immediately previously and
then I hit enter it's surprisingly it
calculates incorrectly it's too but now
that I've done a formula I can copy that
and then I can go all these cells down
here and just paste it like so and voila
there is the familiar Fibonacci sequence
okay
and at least I'm calculating up to 40
6368
okay okay so you people aren't your
sequencer
so now I've got to amaze you okay
Fibonacci sequence what does this have
to do with fire but yet series well
there's a connection here right we're
gonna do another calculation this time
we're going to start with this cell this
is um c5 in case you can't see what
those highlighted cells are I'm gonna do
calculation which is equals and what I'm
what is the ratio because fires a ratio
right Faisal ratio I want to get the
ratio between successive or adjacent
Fibonacci numbers okay I want the ratio
between each pair okay so for instance
I'm gonna look at these pair enough is
what's the ratio this paradigm is what's
the ratio and so on so you think for a
second before I put it all there
how would you get Excel to calculate the
ratio between successive pairs of
numbers anyone would suggest what I
should do it this first so I said equals
no one good so I'm gonna get the cells
that have the two previous numbers in
them so I'm gonna go left
that'll give me that number okay and
then I'm going to divide by the previous
number now the first two numbers I want
so unsurprisingly the ratio is one okay
and as I copy and paste that down I have
another 2 because 2 divided by 1 is 2
but then the next number is 3 divided by
2 which should be 1/2 1/2
now I encourage you before you go any
further - why did this cell cuz you're
gonna need it I'm gonna now copy this
formula further down I've got 5 over 3
that's 1 or 2/3
now I'm gonna have 8 over 5 which is 1.6
exactly then I'm gonna have 13 over 8 21
over thirds here it's time to get messy
because the denominators are starting to
get messy and I'm just going to go all
the way here all right now what's going
on what's happening I'm gonna do a bit
of a tricky
freeze my chopper oh you don't need to
do this okay what's happening as I take
the ratio between increasing Fibonacci
numbers I'm approaching something right
yes
let's try I'm getting really really
close to fight look this fire the top of
the screen right have a look how close
I'm getting actually by this point I'm
already correct - how many just waste is
one two three four five six seven maybe
the eighth one I'm rounding yeah
actually and what is correct if I'm
rounding
yes yes I will let's come back up how
did I do this column College see the way
I did was I'm dividing dividing so
that's why I use the slash slash I'm
dividing successive cells in the
Fibonacci sequence successful numbers
and then I take that and I just copied
all the way down yeah okay so you're
doing this one so what I think was I
said equals divide one Fibonacci number
by the previous one like that b5 divided
by B form okay and then you can anytime
that's what you've got and then once
you've got that one for Mill you can
copy it and paste it wherever you like
and I'm going all the way down here okay
so that's pretty cool Hey look at that
the Fibonacci sequence has given us five
just by comparing successive terms
that's pretty amazing right